[Música]
qué tal buen día es para mí un gusto y
un regocijo estar aquí con ustedes como
ya me presentaron soy irvine in that
tengo 32 años y he dedicado gran parte
de mi vida a prepararme académicamente
tengo una licenciatura tengo una
maestría dos especialidades un doctorado
trabajo en una de las mejores
universidades públicas del país y aunado
a esto tengo algunas investigaciones
sobre el aprendizaje los juegos y los
videojuegos acompañado de toda esta
formalidad académica venía inmiscuida
una creencia de que un profesionista
debe de comportarse de una manera seria
rígida y protocolaria y francamente me
rehúso a creer que la vida es aburrida
busco cambiar el paradigma donde los
adultos no puedan divertirse y resolver
los problemas de su vida todos los días
acompañado de todo esto surgió en mí una
pregunta pueden coadyuvar estas dos
cosas el juego y resolver problemas de
la vida cotidiana
e
imagino un mundo tengo una visión donde
imagino un mundo que todos los adultos
básicamente profesionistas y no
profesionistas puedan resolver los
problemas divirtiéndose de una manera
emocionante e iniciar esta charla con
una confesión tengo tres grandes
pasiones en la vida la primera viajar a
la cual represento durante mucho tiempo
para mí un sueño
la segunda jugar aquella actividad que
se nos dice los adultos que abandonemos
una vez llega a la madurez a nosotros y
la tercera enseñar de formas poco
convencionales pero enseñar si una de
estas tres pasiones no estuviese
francamente mi vida se sentiría monótona
aburrida y carente de sentido vaya sin
sin chispa y entiendo perfectamente que
hay momentos para jugar y hay momentos
para producir con una calidad
extraordinaria
cuando era estudiante siempre soñaba con
viajar desafortunadamente en mis
condiciones económicas y las de mi
familia no lo hacían posible en ese
momento así que una vez que grecia de la
universidad trabajé lo suficiente para
cruzar el océano mi destino londres 12
horas de vuelo la emoción a tope
quería conocer el 'big ben' los
autobuses rojos de dos pisos quería
conocer los soldados con sombreros
graciosos del palacio de buckingham y lo
más importante para mí en ese momento la
estación nueve tres cuartos de la
película de harry potter una vez que
llegué a la ciudad me percaté que ésta
tenía un toque sombrío lúgubre y hasta
cierto punto triste caminaba por las
calles entablaba conversaciones pedía
direcciones y platicaba con gente de la
ciudad y notaba que la gente no sonreía
vaya estaba teniendo lo que se conoce
como un choque cultural extrañaba la
alegría la emoción y el apapacho que se
nos da por el simple hecho de ser
latinos
estando en ese viaje había una pregunta
que no dejaba de dar vueltas en mi
cabeza puede una sonrisa cambiar el día
de alguien sin saberlo aquí va la
explicación resulta que la ciencia ya se
había preguntado lo mismo no
necesariamente con la sonrisa pero sí
con el comportamiento y la forma de
relacionarnos con nosotros en una parte
de nuestro cerebro se encuentra algo que
se llama las neuronas espejo las cuales
tienen el poder de poder imitar
comportamientos que nos llaman la
atención para generar una empatía
natural con las personas pero sobre todo
inconsciente quedé maravillado con el
regalo que me había dado mi primer viaje
las neuronas espejo y cuando cuando
viajaba
después de ese viaje
quedé maravillado y convenientemente
para mí la sonrisa estaba ligada a mi
segunda pasión jugar como les dije antes
soy un adulto que se niega a crecer y
comportarse como otros adultos
convencionales hago lo que los expertos
denominan como gam y fica medida vaya
visualizo la vida como un huevo como un
videojuego cada día a levantar nos
enfrentamos villanos diferentes de
manera inconsciente está el monstruo de
la flojera el grillete de la ignorancia
la cobija de quedarme dormido cinco
minutos más la caja de la visión
limitada que te dice que no puede ser
más que lo que te inculcaron en tu casa
en tu familia en la escuela con tus
amigos o en tu ciudad vaya todos
nosotros tenemos diferentes villanos que
enfrentamos inconscientemente todos los
días
puede que algunas que en algún momento
tú no quieras enfrentar a tu destino
vamos a ver qué sucede con esto bien hay
dos formas de poder enfrentar a tus
villanos
puedes hacerlo con una actitud positiva
o puedes hacerlo lamentándose por tu
mala suerte o bien puedes tomar la peor
de las decisiones puedes no enfrentar a
tus villanos diarios y dejar que éstos
crezcan se acumulen y regresen con más
fuerza
los juegos representan a lógicamente una
simulación de la vida jugamos para
aprender a ganar pero también para
aprender a perder jugamos para trabajar
en equipo y jugamos para mejorar
individualmente bien si tú no juegas a
vencer a tus villanos o dejas pasar de
largo los villanos puede que llegues a
la noche del tc del día del día en el
que dijiste enfrentarlos y no pasa nada
pero al hacerlo estás limitando a tu
persona a ciertas habilidades y
aprendizajes necesarios para tu vida
pongamos un ejemplo si estuviésemos en
un videojuego como zelda para los que
son fanáticos de los videojuegos en su
última versión red of the wild o aliento
de los salvajes tú tienes la opción de
ir directo de inicio del juego al final
para para vencer y enfrentar al
cataclismo pero al hacerlo sin enfrentar
a los villanos previos sin las caídas y
los múltiples sinsabores que te dan
errar una y otra y otra vez y
equivocarte y volverte a equivocar tú
llegas a enfrentar tu destino con una
cantidad limitada de corazones con una
cantidad limitada de herramientas y con
una cantidad limitada de sabiduría
tú enfrentes a tus villa en los diarios
en la vida pasa algo muy similar recibes
una insignia personal que refleja
heroísmo valentía aprendizaje
habilidades vaya representa que has
crecido personalmente y te has
convertido en un gamer de la vida diaria
más completo
pero
qué pasaría bueno convenientemente para
mí el jugar estaba ligado también a mi
siguiente pasión que era enseñar
he tenido la fortuna de ser docente en
diferentes niveles educativos desde
preescolar los más chiquititos de
preescolar hasta estudiantes
universitarios y de posgrado
allí identifique que la escuela no
necesariamente brindaba las mejores
herramientas para poder solucionar
problemáticas de la vida cotidiana de
forma creativa
y me pregunte qué pasaría si la escuela
propiciase un desorden formativo un caos
desde el exterior que se visualice con
mucho ruido carcajadas movimientos y
risas pero desde el interior sea como un
caldo de cultivo para los aprendizajes
un lugar donde los problemas que plantee
de manera controlada y el juego a partir
del juego generen experiencias y
habilidades que te puedan ayudar para
solucionar problemas académicos pero
también para solucionar y aplicar en tu
vida cotidiana visión la que anima en su
libro el código de las mentes
extraordinarias menciona la importancia
de cuestionar tu realidad
para generar una especie de hackeo
cerebral que él denomina ingeniería
cognitiva cada pregunta que lleva que
llega a tu cabeza como zelda y las
neuronas espejo la sonrisa puede
contagiar más sonrisas o la educación
debe de darse como a mí me enseñaron me
llevaron a incorporar dentro de mi
trabajo juegos para que mis estudiantes
aplicaran intercambiarán información
dentro de un ambiente controlado pero
sobre todo basado en problemas que se
pueden aplicar a la vida cotidiana
pongamos un ejemplo visualicen esta
clase una una clase una clase
universitaria los mesabancos están
abiertos en forma de abanico el centro
del aula libre justo en el medio un
jenga marcado con colores y números que
representan las diferentes temáticas y
preguntas que se hacen para los
universitarios los estudiantes grabando
con su celular alentando haciendo relajo
pero sobre todo disfrutando su proceso
de aprendizaje en la puerta que está por
allá y van pasando algunos alumnos que
no están matriculados pero que el relajo
de la clase los incitó para ver qué
estaba sucediendo desde fuera eso se
percibe como una hora libre desde dentro
es una batalla cognitiva y motriz donde
tus habilidades tus aprendizajes y cómo
aplicas la solución de problemas te
pueden hacer acreedor a ganar estas
habilidades que suman el desorden
formativo deja de herramientas que te
pueden ayudar a solucionar problemas
pequeños
o hasta tus propósitos de vida
dentro de este grupo de universitarios
siempre me pasa que tengo un alumno que
es de mayor edad que el resto de sus
compañeros en esta ecuación lo vamos a
llamar alfonso alfonso no tenía
problemas al igual que el resto de los
universitarios en pasar a una clase
donde jugará durante dos horas pasaron
los días las semanas los meses y llegó
el momento de realizar el examen
semestral el examen que acreditaba todo
lo aprendido durante la materia y del
cual dependía el que tú pudieras pasar
al siguiente semestre o repitiera el
curso alfonso nervioso hacia su examen y
una vez realizado y calificado el
obtiene una de las mejores notas de todo
el salón sorprendido se acerca al final
de la clase y me dice profe francamente
yo pensé que únicamente venía a jugar a
tu clase pero cuando estaba haciendo el
examen y leía cada una de las preguntas
venían las respuestas automáticamente a
mi cabeza ese es el efecto que se busca
cuando tú gámiz fika tus aprendizajes
juegas te diviertes aprendes aplicas
sumas habilidades que en conjunto te
hacen un mejor gamer de la vida diaria
para solucionar los problemas que la
vida te plantea
recapitulando es importante cuestionar
tu realidad es importante resolver es
importante vencer a tus villanos diarios
pero es más importante que lo hagas con
una actitud positiva porque
inconscientemente y gracias a las
neuronas espejo estamos ocasionando una
reacción en cadena de personas que
abordan los problemas con una actitud
diferente generamos una cultura gamer de
la vida diaria que está preparada para
la vida que disfruta lo que hace y lo
más importante que genera felicidad
la propuesta es clara tú y sólo tú eres
la persona que maneja el juego de tu
vida bien la vida te puede dar retos
pequeños y grandes pero solo depende de
ti disfrutar el proceso y disfrutar cada
nivel que te plantea la vida muchas
gracias ha sido un placer estar aquí con
ustedes
[Aplausos]